[موسيقى]
ننقل لكم المشهد والصوره من داخل احد
المنازل المتضرره والمستهدف في لق اثنين
مخيم جباليا رغم الدمار لا مكان لماوى ولا
للنزوح هنا يتم طهي الطعام على الحطب علما
انه عدم توفر الغاز وال الاشياء الضروريه
للطعام هذا هو احد المنازل في بلوك اثنين
في مخيم جباليا رغم القصف ورغم قصف هذا
المنزل هذا الحاج هو جنسيه المصري جنسيه
الجنسيه المصريه لا معي له شو شو مته كمان
حجه مقعده من مصر ابنه استشهد الوحيد
ومعاه خمس بنات
ومرته ح لهم لا هم كلهم ابنهم اللي استشهد
ابنهم استشهد يعني الان ما فيش له حدا
يعني الح الحجه مشلوله فوق مقعده
حطين هم من سكان نصر هذا هو المشهد كما
تشاهدون تماما من داخل مخيم جباليا في احد
المنازل التي ترفض الخروج ل مناطق الاواء
والنزوح رغم قصف المنزل يتم باشياء بسيطه
اعاده الحياه في داخل المنزل رغم القصف
الشديد في داخل مخيم جباليا وبلوك اثنين
تحديدا هذا هو المشهد تماما كما
تشاهدون